so I'm sure lots of people who've given
talks with Stephen in the audience will
both have felt the same you're giving
the talk a it's nerve-racking Stephens
there you're talking about real things I
was talking about cosmic strings and
he'd worked on these and and I was
thinking I wonder what he's thinking and
then you hear the click click you're
thinking it's fountain error mistake or
he's gonna say this is rubbish and
you've got to sort of carry on and you
stop and then the organizer carry on
it's ok and you carry on and then it's
not that he puts his hand up rent he
can't do that so just the the speaker
turns on and out comes these words and I
was okay it was a question and I had an
idea of the answer to the question and
so but that feeling of I think has it
discovered something or not that I was
wrong I heard that very well in some
sense it is a sad day but actually in
other ways it's a triumph in that given
that he was a cup given a couple of
years to live in the 1960s the fact that
he made it into his 70s is a truly
amazing achievement he was so determined
to succeed so determined to keep alive I
mean he was told he should be dead
within whilst he was doing his PhD and
along the way he did all this truly
astounding physics and which you know
for somebody with no disability at all
would have been an amazing achievement
but to do that from wheelchair without
access to you know when I'm thinking
about something I've often scribbled
something on a piece of paper or I'll
just fiddle around with things not being
able to do that having to do the whole
thing essentially in your head is a
truly astounding achievement so I think
probably the main thing to be doing
today is sort of celebrating a truly
exceptional and completely unlikely life
so packing what he did and to make the
contributions that he has is just
staggering but he's a huge loss you can
tell from the coverage he was a very
charismatic individual I actually only
met him once so I met him when I was an
undergraduate so back in the 1980s
before he lost his voice so I I heard
him give a talk in his own voice even
then the
disease have progressed to a point where
he couldn't talk clearly and so he
actually had one of his PhD students
along with him who was kind of
interpreting what he was saying so he
was giving the talk and then the student
was sort of repeating what he was saying
so that people who weren't kind of tuned
into being able to understand what he
was saying
could hear the talk as well to be honest
I remember absolutely nothing about the
content of the talk itself but I do
remember Stephen Hawking and it really
it wasn't just the fact that he was
somebody you know in a wheelchair who
was hard to understand who were saying
all these amazing things there was
something about him that kind of he did
have that sort of charismatic
personality yes whether it be from his
book of course brief history of time
which I think has sold twenty million
copies through to the lectures he gave
through to the broadcast see he gave his
media contributions
you know his efforts with the National
Health Service you know supporting that
he he touched everything and people
listened to him they wanted to
let's just described a couple of the
things right because they're just so
extraordinary what he did from his PhD
days where he he I think was influenced
by roger penrose roger penrose who who
was a is also a genius but working on
general relativity and hawking and
Penrose realized that if you thought of
our universe as containing sort of
ordinary matter the kind of things that
you and i are made of and that that
matter would evolve in such a way that
if you traced it back in time the
universe simply had to have a
singularity it had to have a region
where the space and time diverged they
had curvature singularities that meant
the equations broke down so many ways
general relativity itself predicted its
own demise because the equations brought
down and the what Penrose had done was
he'd spotted this for black holes and
what Hawking did was he he extrapolated
it to the universe and and in doing so
he basically sure the universe had to
have at least at this classical picture
what we'd call a Big Bang where space
and time emerged from so that was the
first major thing he did but then he
went about trying to address it and he
was interested in in black holes
naturally because of this this type of
work and in that in the 70s he did
something quite extraordinary
he basically brought general relativity
quantum mechanics and thermodynamics
together
and he in and in in this mix he
demonstrated that because of the the
influence of quantum mechanics that a
black hole that we always think of has
been black because nothing can escape
from it from its event horizon he
demonstrated it I mean this must have
been such a dramatic calculation to do
what I'm about to describe he
demonstrated that it's not black
actually the black hole has a
temperature and if something's got a
temperature it will radiate and it was
radiating particles so the black hole
because of quantum mechanics was
radiating particles so it was actually
shrinking
it has revolutionized the world of
theoretical physics this concept of
hawking radiation and there's no
question that if they'd have been able
to discover it he'd have got the Nobel
Prize just him it had been a solo a
Nobel Prize for him and they haven't
found it because a typical star the the
temperature of this radiation that's
being emitted is so low that we can't
detect it we just kept a typical star
like black hole above a solar mass we
just can't detect it but the the the
idea is so firmly rooted in quantum
mechanics and relativity that it's
accepted that this this will happen that
black holes will evaporate in the 1980s
he turned his attention back back again
to the beginning of the universe and the
he asked the question you know okay if
the universe's got this singularity what
can we do about it and he came up with a
proposal with another wonderful
physicist called Jim Hartle
that actually the universe effect we
didn't have a beginning that is called
the no boundary proposal and he what he
argued was as I go back in time to what
we would have said was this singular
point at which that actually the time
becomes imaginary and in becoming an
imaginary time it actually affects you
allows you to round off this singularity
and so there is no boundary and so he
would turn this on its head and you'd
say that the universe began from a
quantum fluctuation which produced this
initial starting point which then
emerged to give our universe today and
this is the wave function of the
universe he in quantum mechanics we use
wave functions all the time to describe
positions of particles at different
times he decided along with Hartl that
there should be a wave function
describing the universe and so you did
it and and we don't know if it's right
that I think Jim and Stephen certainly
believed it was right people are working
on this all the time to try and
understand it but it these three areas
just transformed our feel
even things like his voice which clearly
since that voice synthesiser was created
he could have if he'd wanted to moved
over to something which would have
sounded much more naturalistic but that
was it defined him and it was actually
all that Stephen Hawking and that's
that's kind of a unique personality was
even printed in him in all those well
you know in in the way he sounded and
the way he looked and he traded on it is
the wrong word he you know he used it as
a way to to present the subject to
present science in a way that was sort
of accessible and different and made
people think about things and through a
whole variety popularly the you know the
Big Bang Theory the Simpsons you name it
he was on it at some time or another
he did something else which people that
are in danger of forgetting it did a
couple of things I just like to add in
one is in the in the 1979-1980
time early eighties there was a an idea
called the inflationary universe emerged
with people like Alan Guth and Andrei
Linde and Paul Stine hardened and and
the old break but Hawking was there
Hawking Mawson Stewart wrote this
fantastic paper on inflation but in
particular at a workshop which Hawking
helped organize a whole group of
cosmologists got together and they
basically discovered that inflation
could give us with the seeds the
perturbations which led to the
structures that we see in the universe
so Hawking was involved at the ground
level here sorting out the perturbations
we seed the structures of our universe
and which seemed to have been confirmed
by the beautiful details that we see
from the Planck Cosmic Microwave
Background the detector so he did that
but he did something else which had to
forgotten about until today that back in
the very early days of his visa research
when he was thinking about black holes
he thought about what happens when two
black holes merge together now these
black holes have got an area associated
with them and he showed that the area of
the of the combined black hole had to be
bigger than the sum of the two smaller
black holes and that meant he could put
a bound on the amount of radiation
gravitational waves that could be
emitted and it's sort of really nice
that within the last two years this has
been detected precisely these
gravitational waves have been detected
by the LIGO detector and from the merger
of two black holes and they fit
beautifully with the ideas of Hawking
demonstrating these bounds which people
have tended to forget about but he was
there thinking about gravitational waves
from black holes way before these
experiments were done I was lucky enough
to meet him I didn't meet him so much in
the last few years our past didn't
overlap very much and he wasn't that
well but in the 80s and 90s I met him a
lot so there's a yeah I've got some
happy memories I mean one of them in
life in general you you have periods of
luck and I've had many of them and one
was that I went to Newcastle to do a PhD
and at the same time a postdoc arrived
that's someone that's just finished
their PhD and that postdoc was Ian moss
and Ian Moss was Hawking student and
they'd been working on inflation and I I
think they got so into it that ian had
run a bit late with his writing of his
PhD so he came he'd missed the usual job
cycle and arrived to with us at
Newcastle well he was still working with
it with Steven and Steven came up with
in a few weeks or months at least to
giver to give a seminar so this was so
exciting for me right that Stephen
Hawking coming is it early 82 or 83 and
he came and he gave the seminar is it
was the time before he became ill and
had to have the truck up to me and and
so the voice synthesiser he could still
speak and so for the first 20 minutes of
the talk you could listen to him who's
actually giving the seminar but such as
motor neuron disease it's a muscle
wasting disease so his muscles gradually
would weaken and so his speech would
become slurred at which point the
graduate students then took over his
graduate students but Ian was doing it
because he had been his graduate student
so Ian finished off the top from in
other words what would happen Stephen
would speak very quietly it's the yin
would be listening and then Ian would
say what Stephen was talking about and
it was about the wave function of the
universe they'd just come up with this
idea of this wave function describing
the whole universe anyway so the talk
was fantastic and then we went had tea
biscuits and and and we said to Stephen
well we usually take the seminar speaker
for a beer afterwards he went yeah okay
well the beer was down at the key side
it was in the cooperage arms down at the
bottom of the key side which is a long
way from where the physics department
was
so we went off off we went Stephen in
his wheelchair we went down and for
those under no no Newcastle it's very
steep so we're coming down this big
steep hill to get to the Cupra stand
onto the key side and about three
crosses our way down this and even
steeper steps and we said to Stephen
well if you go
you carry on down there just follow the
path down and we'll just go down these
steps and he went no I'm coming down the
steps now these were really narrow steps
and there's loads of them down sit and
we're going no no it's really not not
good this and he said no I'm going down
these steps you're taking me we took a
corner reach of the wheelchair and it
was a heavy wheelchair and we very very
slowly went down the steps with him and
then we carried on and the cooperage had
another set of steps to get in and we
lifted him in and then he said and it
was packed downstairs and people were
coming up to him immediately of course
and even in the 80s it was really well
known and they were coming up and it's
Stephen Hawking having patting me on the
back and we said well we sometimes go
upstairs I said let's go upstairs and so
we went up and then he brought us all
around and we had it we all had a great
time with him and then we all brought
him back down again afterwards and we
went back and went to his van so that
they could then drive back to Cambridge
and and and the the striking thing is
and I think it sort of sums up what
Stephen was was like was this
determination this determination not to
let obstacles get in his way and he knew
he could have gone down there but for
some reason which really he wanted to
come down these steps and that drive
that determination I think it says a lot
about why he survived as long as he did
that ability to just keep going yes it
was a great experience and give seminars
if you had lunch a few times when I've
been there nothing I'd had lunch and he
would just come up and join you because
he he he wanted to chat he wanted to
talk and that was a that was when that
first happened
I remember thinking it must be no one
else around but now I just wanted to
talk about physics and wonderful man
it's called an antiparticle literally
pop into existence so the particle
escapes and the antiparticle falls into
the black hole